all of the exciting things that happen
in each of our lives right like okay
this other guy was like well I'm not
rich I'm a regular guy and I was like
that's fine but like I'm not a regular
girl like I'm I'm not so like if you're
if you are gonna date me like either you
have to be able to handle that or you
yourself also wants to not be like
regular like I don't think I could like
just an average person like that to me
it's boring Okay so
is there like us do you care okay would
you be cool if a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him he wouldn't be able
to afford my engagement ring I'm getting
an eight carat cushion cut vintage
engagement ring if you make 45 000 a
year it would take what
four years no eight years how much I
don't know anything about Rings how much
how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
my ring has to Sparkle from across the
street that [ __ ] it's gonna blind people
that's so superficial that's like so
superficial but it's about so much more
than that it's about the fact that you
can afford that right I go to yoga with
this girl it was an eight carat diamond
engagement ring yeah the weed company
and drives an Audi so it's about more
than just it's about the fact that you
can't afford that but you you're you
ain't her you ain't her
because I'm worth it she's gonna end up
cute it was a cubic zirconia that's what
she's got it's a fake one that's what
she's gonna end up with and this is this
is this is the thing is that these are
supposed to be business-minded women I
remember when I was talking to my man
about marriage you know how much my
ideal wedding costs it costs 59 Japan
including the ring and the honeymoon
1500 pounds that is it
too many people start relationships in
debt she hasn't got a car but she wants
a 200k that's ridiculous so you're gonna
have a you're gonna have a two 200k ring
and eat what chips mashed potato
what yeah I I get into it here just wait
okay well I'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because I'm telling you know but not not
in a good way not in a good way I'm
telling you like my dad would if my mom
asked for that from my dad my dad would
have told her to go find a new boyfriend
because there's no way in hell he was
going to spend two hundred thousand
dollars on an engagement ring and that's
something no and that's a
multi-millionaire in the top half a
percent who had 10 kids my mom never
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right he
wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like yeah she like is it
nice yeah oh no I see it like do you
hear how she's trying to diminish like
like she's like oh well he built himself
to be that yeah like what what have you
done he's there that's what you want
he's he's there that's the whole point
he's not he's dummy and it's like I grew
up with the men that you so-called one a
day like all of my brothers make six
figures that are older than me so it's
like she doesn't listen at all she feels
like she knows it all I always say would
you prefer a poor man with ambition or a
rich man with none oh a poor man with
ambition she wants a rich family poor
man with ambition because she don't get
it she would want to reach
I've dated the opposite and it is not
yeah it is here like to me that's like
such an unwise investment to spend 200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my God no no oh my God no that's like
I would rather put that in a college
fund for our kids or like yeah they'll
have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like I know
for me like I told you like my my status
is going up like I just did a music
festival where I made 30 grand over the
weekend in one weekend you know what I
mean like I need somebody who can be on
that level right but the problem is like
guys don't care about your money
right behind there I I know but it
doesn't like you know like
I'm just I think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this like to
me these are like crazy high standards
so today I listen to my dating coach she
said you do not get your expectation you
get your minimum standard
mm-hmm
see I wish I I have more experienced
these types these type of these type of
women were new to me at the time because
I wasn't used to like the girls I grew
up around really weren't this crazy like
I grew up with athletes I've never seen
anything I've had that before yeah and
so I like I wish I could talk to her now
because now that I've dealt with crazy
yeah I know how to like talk to them in
a more direct way but at the time I'm
like what are you doing I want to see I
know that where are you now you know I
could oh I could tell you look I'll show
you she's still doing the same [ __ ] you
can do Tick Tock tailor the sparkle
so she's still single yeah of course she
is she's always gonna be single she's
got bad then she choose
it's like like this is what a lot of a
lot of girls come in older
and they raise their standards higher
even though the products like like they
don't put them that's why Kevin Samuels
used to say after 30 you put yourself on
sale
like you know because it's one thing to
come in a guy with like a humble a
humble attitude you know what I'm saying
like a lot of guys will date a girl with
a kid but like the problem is the girls
that have kids will act like they're
better than the men's yeah like they
don't humble themselves and it's even
with her like you've never had a
boyfriend and you're in your 30s like
that's crazy yeah she's never had a
boyfriend no never and she wants that
ring and she thinks that she's gonna get
a man and she's never had a boyfriend
but the thing is is that now that's even
worse because nowadays you've got all
the tick tocks and the Instagrams Who
the hell's gonna want that no but if you
was a man and you was looking at her
page oh no look at this look at this
this is one of the least self-aware
things and having the waiter and then
and then she's like she wants a
six-figure man and he and he like
politely was like oh you're gonna film
this too like you realize
tongue-in-cheek and she just like oh
thank you
and then she's like oh I'm an influencer
right over her hair you have a hundred
thousand followers on Tick Tock you get
200 views on you like I I've been I
don't even call myself an influencer
and it's just I think people just look
at us to laugh because like and she's
not a bad looking girl if she didn't do
it oh she's not great no her attitude
makes her like I'd say she's fine but
like like I don't think she's like high
I just think she's average but like her
attitude a lot of the prettiest girls I
know the ugliest inside they're really
ugly
and and no look at her no flared nose no
why would you there's a dating coach
well it's 35 years old and you've got a
dating coach
I mean at 35 don't you know how to date
or doesn't a dating coach tell you don't
take out your phone no you see this is
the problem like this is a red pill fact
so or basically like a hundred percent
of women want 20 of men so girls have
been going through their their 20s and
their even their early 30s like they're
side chicks yeah and so they've never
really had any relationship experience
so they don't know how to like vet men
properly right and so it's like they get
to 35 and they're still like mentally a
teenager because they've never had a
real relationship and so it's like yeah
so that's like what you see is she's
mentally still a teenager
there's a lot of them all out yeah
there's a lot I'm getting older and
that's why like you can't have a
conversation about like hey it's not
about happiness like that's an adult
conversation but like it's like you're
talking to teenagers but yeah but sooner
or later it's gonna bet it's itself out
the mental women ratio because they're
really going to realize that half of you
women are stupid we don't want you and
it's gonna even itself up and then
you're gonna end up learning about your
dogs no that's what happens yeah like I
don't I don't see like I don't see I her
getting like saved unless